chapter xxii king harald clears the
western isles of vikings king harald
learned that vikings harried in the
Westlands who during the winter stayed
in the islands beyond the sea therefore
every summer he equipped ships and men
to search for them in islands and
outlying scary's and wherever the
Vikings became aware of the presence of
his fleet they all fled and most of them
took to the sea but when he grew tired
of this one summer king harald sailed
across the sea with his fleet he first
came to the Shetland Islands where he
slew all Vikings who did not escape by
flight then he sailed to the Orkneys and
there cleaned out all of Vikings from
there he sailed all the way to the
Hebrides and harried there he killed
many Vikings who previously had had men
and ships he had many a battle there but
when he arrived West in man the
population there had heard what a
depredations he had made in those lands
and all the people fled to Scotland so
that the land was altogether void of
people and all chapels had been removed
too so that when king harald and his men
went on land they found no booty
as says Homme Coffee the ships Lord
shields many shore descent off times the
sea kings on sandy foreshore swordplay
urged to Harry air from their fight
strong foe all of the Scotsman timidly
took to flight and toured to the
mainland
hide them it was at this time that I've
are the son of Earl Ragnar vald of myrrh
fell in battle to make up for that loss
King Harald when he sailed back east
gave Earl Ragna vault dominion over the
Orkneys and the Shetland Islands but
Rock no vault promptly gave both lands
to his brother sigurth and the latter
remained behind in the West when the
King returned to Norway before that he
had bestowed the earldom on sigurth
then saw Stein the red the son of Olaf
the white and of out the deep minded
joined him and they harried in Scotland
taking possession of Caithness and of
the Hebrides as far as actual Sparkie
[Applause]
sigurth slew mell brigth a tooth Escada
shell and fastened his head to his
saddle straps the calf of his leg struck
the tusks protruding from the skull
mortification set in and he died from it
he is buried by excels Becky thereupon
Gotham his son ruled the islands one
year and died childless then Vikings
both Danes and Norwegians settled in the
islands
[Music]
you
[Music]